Here are my answers.
The prior for fire is 0.001
times the probability that the neighbor now correctly said, yes, it burns, which is 0.9.
He lies with a probability of 0.1, so the complement is 0.9.
This gives us 0.0009.
For the complement, the prior of no fire, is 0.999,
but now the neighbor would have lied, which multiplies with 0.1,
which gives us 0.0999.
Now, these two values don't add up to 1.
The normalizer will be 1 over these two things, which is about 9.92.
Multiplying these with their normalizer gives us approximately 0.0089 and 0.991.
So the answer your neighbor gave you--yes, it burns--
raised your probability from 0.001 to 0.0089.
It's still small, but it's significantly larger.
In fact, it's approximately 0.9 times as large as the initial probability.
The reason why that is the case is it relates to the 0.9 probability of speaking the truth.
It's not exactly 0.9 because of normalization, but it's approximately 0.9.